Estamos luchando contra uno de los procesos de aprendizaje
evolutivamente mejor conservados que ahora conocemos científicamente
uno que se conserva
en los sistemas nerviosos más básicos conocidos.
El proceso de aprendizaje basado en la recompensa
se llama refuerzo positivo y negativo,
y básicamente va así.
Vemos comida que parece rica,
nuestro cerebro dice: "¡Calorías!.. ¡Sobrevivir!"
Comemos la comida, nos gusta,
sabe bien.
Y especialmente con el azúcar,
nuestros cuerpos le dicen a nuestro cerebro:
"Recuerda lo que estás comiendo y dónde lo encontraste".
Establecemos este recuerdo dependiente del contexto
y aprendemos a repetir el proceso la próxima vez.
Ver comida,
comer alimentos, sentirse bien,
repetir.
Detonante, comportamiento, recompensa.
Sencillo, ¿no?
Después de un tiempo nuestros cerebros creativos dicen
"¿Sabes qué?
puedes usarlo para algo más que para recordar dónde está la comida.
Ya sabes, la próxima vez que te sientas mal,
¿por qué no comes algo rico para que te sientas mejor?"
Agradecemos a nuestros cerebros la buena idea,
lo probamos y aprendemos rápido
que si comemos chocolate o helado cuando estamos enojados o tristes,
nos sentimos mejor.
El mismo proceso,
solo un detonante diferente.
En lugar de la señal de hambre procedente de nuestro estómago,
esta señal emocional, sentirse triste,
desencadena esas ganas de comer.
Tal vez en nuestros años de adolescencia,
éramos unos nerds en la escuela,
y veíamos a los rebeldes fumar y pensábamos,
"Yo quiero ser estar a la onda".
Así que empezamos a fumar.
El hombre de Marlboro no era un idiota y no fue accidental.
Estar a la onda,
fumar para estar a la onda,
sentirse bien. Repetir.
Detonante, comportamiento, recompensa.
Y cada vez que lo hacemos,
aprendemos a repetir el proceso
y se convierte en un hábito.
Después,
el estar estresados desencadena la necesidad de fumar
o comer algo dulce.
Con estos mismos procesos cerebrales,
hemos pasado de aprender a sobrevivir
a matarnos literalmente a nosotros mismos con estos hábitos.
La obesidad y el tabaquismo están entre las principales causas
evitables de morbilidad y mortalidad en el mundo.
Así que de vuelta a mi respiración.
¿Y si en lugar de luchar contra nuestro cerebro,
o tratar de obligarlo a poner atención,
usaramos este proceso de aprendizaje natural basado en la recompensa
pero añadiendo un giro?
¿Y si somos realmente curiosos
sobre lo que ocurría en nuestra experiencia momentánea?
Voy a dar un ejemplo.
En mi laboratorio se estudió si
el entrenamiento mental podría ayudar a las personas a dejar de fumar.
Al igual que al tratar de obligarme a poner atención a la respiración,
podrían tratar de obligarme a dejar de fumar.
Y la mayoría lo ha intentado antes y ha fallado,
en promedio, seis veces.
Con entrenamiento de la mente,
dejamos de forzar y en su lugar nos centramos en ser curiosos.
De hecho, incluso les permitimos fumar.
¿Qué? Sí, dijimos, "Adelante, fumen,
solo sean realmente atentos sobre lo que se siente al hacerlo".
¿Y de qué se dan cuenta?
Bueno, este es un ejemplo de una de nuestros fumadores.
Dijo: "Fumar conscientemente:
huele a queso apestoso
y sabe a productos químicos,
¡Qué asco!"
Sabía cognitivamente que fumar era malo para ella,
por eso se unió a nuestro programa.
Lo que descubrió solo por estar curiosamente consciente al fumar
era que fumar sabe a mierda.
(Risas)
Pasó del conocimiento a la sabiduría.
Pasó de saber en su cabeza que fumar era malo para ella
a saberlo profundamente
y se rompió el hechizo del tabaquismo.
Comenzó a desencantarse con su comportamiento.
La corteza prefrontal,
la parte más joven de nuestro cerebro desde una perspectiva evolutiva,
entiende en un nivel intelectual que no debemos fumar.
Y trata arduamente de ayudarnos a cambiar nuestro comportamiento,
para ayudarnos a dejar de fumar,
para ayudarnos a dejar de comer esa segunda, tercera, cuarta galleta.
A esto le llamamos el control cognitivo.
Usamos la cognición para controlar nuestro comportamiento.
Desafortunadamente,
esta es también la primera parte de nuestro cerebro
que se apaga cuando nos estresamos,
algo que no es tan útil.
Todos podemos relacionar esto con nuestra propia experiencia.
Somos mucho más propensos a gritar a nuestro cónyuge o hijos